in the last video we covered the basics
of what an adjustable rate mortgage is
and how it's different from a fixed-rate
mortgage but you may have heard another
term that seems to be a mixture of the
two and that's a hybrid hybrid arm or a
hybrid adjustable rate mortgage and a
hybrid when we use that word generally
means a mix of things and that's exactly
what a hybrid arm is it's a mix of fixed
it's a mix it's a mix of fixed and
adjustable and an adjustable rate
mortgage so what do we mean by mix of a
fixed and adjustable rate mortgage
well you might hear something like a you
might hear something like a 5-1 a 5-1
hybrid arm hybrid arm what does that
mean well that means that the first five
years of the mortgage it behaves like a
fixed mortgage and then after that it
becomes adjustable so in the case that
we used in the video on adjustable rate
mortgages we saw that as your as your
benchmark 1-year Treasury rate
fluctuates that every year your
adjustable rate mortgage resets and if
interest rates go high enough it might
become unfavorable relative to the fixed
rate and this was just for the scenario
that we were looking at well in a 5-1
hybrid arm what would happen is that the
first five years it's a fixed rate
mortgage the first five years it is a
fixed rate mortgage and then after that
it adjusts it adjusts Justices one two
three four five so the first five years
it's a fixed rate mortgage and then
after that it adjusts just like an
adjustable rate and if it had the same
properties as the adjustable rate that
we saw on the vision in the video and
adjustable rate mortgages then we start
adjusting so that's for that year and
then the year after that maybe let's see
interest rates have gone down a little
bit so we pay a premium over the over
the Treasury so we start adjusting so a
question is well why would someone want
to do this one one why would a borrower
want
this and then why does a bank do it when
we talked about adjustable rate
mortgages we talked about this idea of
interest rate risk that an adjustable
rate mortgage a borrower takes on the
interest rate risk if interest rates go
up the borrower the borrower will have
to pay more interest but the lender is
protected on the other hand for a
fixed-rate if interest rates go up it's
the lender who has to take on that risk
while the borrower is protected while
with the hybrid it's in between the
first five years the borrower is
protected they know that hey look I know
what my payments going to be for those
five years and then after that it
adjusts and that's also from a lenders
point of view they're like okay well I
will take on the interest rate risk for
the first five years but then after that
because it may be your students really
hard to predict what interest rates are
going to be doing in five or six or
seven or ten or fifteen years then it
floats and and the borrower takes it on
it's not even the case that the
Bahrainis will even has to take on this
this this risk it could be the case that
the borrower is buying some type of a
property where they think that they will
either sell the property or maybe
they'll refinance the property but
especially if they think they're going
to sell the property in the next five
years this could make a lot of sense
especially if they get a lower rate than
they would have gotten with a fixed-rate
for example the rate that they might
have gotten might have looked something
more like it might have looked something
more like it should we clear it might
have been a lower rate than the fix
story in fact very likely for the same
credit risk it might have been a lower
rate and then after five years and then
after five years it's a lower rate
because the bank is taking on less of
the interest rate risk especially when
you go out or when you go out beyond
your five and then it would adjust so
then after that so that's the spur so
then and then after that it will adjust
so the incentives okay look if I think
if I think I'm going to sell this house
or refinance this house which means take
out another loan to pay this loan off if
I think I'm going to be able to do
either of those things in the next five
years maybe it makes a lot of sense for
me to do this so a hybrid both parties
are kind of mixing there they're both
taking different pieces of the interest
rate risk and once again depending on
your scenario it
might make sense to think about
something like a hybrid arm if you feel
very confident that you could either
take on the variable risk the interest
rate risk that will happen after year 5
or you think that this property is going
to be something that you might own or
can it or that you'll only own for the
next five years or that you might
refinance in some way or maybe you'll be
able to pay it off maybe you're
expecting an inheritance in year four
and so you could just pay off the
property and or pay off the loan and you
won't have to worry about all of these
bits all of this business right over
here